Before we get started today, I'd like to ask you to take a moment to fill out our listener survey. We want to learn more about you and what you think of this podcast. So if you would, please go to our website, www.spereatingof Psychology.org, and look for the link to our listener's survey. We'd really appreciate it. Now on to the episode. What does retirement look like now? Forget the stereotype of a goodbye party in the break room followed by endless days on the golf course
在今天开始之前，我想请大家花点时间填写我们的听众调查问卷。我们想更多地了解您，以及您对本播客的看法。如果您愿意，请访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org，并查找听众调查问卷的链接。我们将不胜感激。现在进入本期节目。现在的退休生活是什么样的？忘掉那种在休息室举行告别派对，随后就是无尽的高尔夫球时光的刻板印象吧，
or sitting in front of the TV. Instead of an abrupt and permanent exit from the workforce, today's retirement often unfolds slowly over time as people move in and out of post-retirement jobs. This shift, along with an aging population, is reflected in U.S. workforce demographics. Nearly one quarter of U.S. workers are older than 55, and the Bureau of Labor Statistics predicts
或者整天坐在电视机前。今天的退休生活不再是突然且永久地退出职场，而是随着人们在退休后的工作中进进出出，往往会缓慢地展开。这种转变，加上人口老龄化，反映在美国的劳动力人口结构中。近四分之一的美国劳动者年龄超过 55 岁，美国劳工统计局预测，
that the number of workers older than 75 will almost double by 2030. So what do these shifts mean for modern retirement? How has the rise of remote work and the gig economy change the way people plan for and experience retirement? How does retirement and post-retirement work affect people's mental, physical, and emotional health? If you're close to retirement yourself,
到 2030 年，75 岁以上的劳动者人数将几乎翻一番。那么，这些变化对现代退休意味着什么？远程办公和零工经济的兴起如何改变了人们规划和体验退休生活的方式？退休和退休后的工作如何影响人们的心理、身体和情感健康？如果您自己也快要退休了，
what questions should you be asking to determine whether it's the right time to cut the cord? And if retirement is still years away for you, you, what should you do now to set yourself up for a happy retirement in the future? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Mo Wang, a university distinguished professor at the Warrington College of Business at the University of Florida. He is also the Associate Dean for Research and Strategic
您应该问自己哪些问题来确定现在是否是“断开连接”的最佳时机？如果距离您退休还有几年时间，您现在应该做些什么来为未来的幸福退休生活做好准备？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是佛罗里达大学沃灵顿商学院的杰出大学教授王茂（音译）博士。他同时也是负责研究和战略的副院长、管理系主任以及人力资源研究中心主任。
initiatives, chair of the management department, and director of the Human Resource Research Research Center. Dr. Wang is an industrial organizational and developmental psychologist whose work focuses on retirement, as well as older worker employment. He was the editor of the Oxford Handbook of Retirement and is currently editor-in-chief of the journal Work, Aging, and Retirement. Dr. Wang, thank you for joining us today. Oh, thank you very much for having me. I'm really glad to be here. Well, let's start by exploring the idea that I just mentioned in the introduction, which is that for many people, retirement is no longer an abrupt end to their working life, but more like a slow process of transition. There's a term that you and other researchers use for that, which is bridge employment.
王博士是一位工业组织和发展心理学家，他的工作重点是退休以及老年人就业。他曾担任《牛津退休手册》的编辑，目前是《工作、老龄化与退休》期刊的主编。王博士，感谢您今天加入我们的节目。哦，非常感谢您的邀请。我很高兴来到这里。那么，让我们从我在介绍中提到的观点开始探讨，即对于许多人来说，退休不再是职业生涯的突然终结，而更像是一个缓慢的过渡过程。您和其他研究人员对此有一个术语，叫做“桥梁就业”。
How common is bridge employment these days, and what does it look like for most people? Oh, so bridge employment simply just means people after they retire, they still engage in some paid activities, paid work activities. And it's actually pretty common. So in the early, in the 90s and the early 21st century, we see about like half of the retirees during retirement after they finish their career job, they would engage in bridge employment. And actually, before the pandemic, near like 2016 to 2018, we see actually two out of the three
如今“桥梁就业”有多普遍？对大多数人来说，它是什么样的？哦，桥梁就业简单来说就是人们在退休后，仍然从事一些有偿活动，即有偿工作活动。这实际上非常普遍。在 90 年代和 21 世纪初，我们看到大约一半的退休人员在结束职业生涯后，会从事桥梁就业。实际上，在疫情之前，大约在 2016 年到 2018 年间，我们看到三分之二的
retirees were engaged. in bridging employment before they fully retire. So the general trend is people actually are taking more and more bridging employment opportunities over time. However, pandemic actually made a big difference. So we see actually people who retired during the pandemic years and the actually bridging employment rates. So the coming back to the work kind of probability decreased a little bit.
退休人员在完全退休前都从事过桥梁就业。因此，总的趋势是人们随着时间的推移，实际上正在接受越来越多的桥梁就业机会。然而，疫情确实造成了很大的不同。我们看到在疫情期间退休的人，他们的桥梁就业率，也就是重返职场的可能性，确实有所下降。
So that's actually one of the reasons we're experiencing labor force shortage right now. So if those people come back to the pre-pandemic bridge employment activities, then we actually would have more labor force participation in the whole population. So has the rise of the gig economy made it easier for people to find post-retirement jobs? I mean, are more people leaving the corporate world to become? Uber drivers, or is this a case of people needing money? I mean, what are the factors that are at play? Oh, so right now we don't have a very systematic research about gig economy's impact on bridge employment.
这实际上是我们目前经历劳动力短缺的原因之一。如果这些人回到疫情前的桥梁就业活动中，那么我们整个群体的劳动力参与率实际上会更高。那么，零工经济的兴起是否让人们更容易找到退休后的工作？我的意思是，是否更多的人离开企业界去当优步司机了，还是说这只是人们需要钱的情况？我的意思是，有哪些因素在起作用？哦，目前我们还没有关于零工经济对桥梁就业影响的系统性研究。
And there are some preliminary evidence showing that gig economy does offer autonomy for older retirees if they want to come back to labor force participation. And because gig economy allows people to actually choose when to work and allows people to have a lot of autonomy in terms like how to take the payment and sometimes you also bypass the tax situation. So yeah, so gig economy is generally considered to be easier for all the workers or retirees to come back to the workforce. But a lot of time, people are not really working for the money, right? So especially when people retire and when they start to receive social security benefits, actually pay may not be a very important issue. So a lot of times people want the social environment for working, right?
有一些初步证据表明，如果老年退休人员想重返劳动力市场，零工经济确实为他们提供了自主权。而且因为零工经济允许人们选择工作时间，并允许人们在支付方式上有很大的自主权，有时甚至可以绕过税务问题。所以，是的，零工经济通常被认为更容易让老年劳动者或退休人员重返职场。但很多时候，人们并不是真的为了钱而工作，对吧？所以，特别是当人们退休并开始领取社会保障福利时，薪水可能并不是一个非常重要的问题。所以很多时候，人们想要的是工作的社交环境，对吧？
So they enjoy social relationships at work. Sometimes you may meet like a Uber driver who's a little bit older and who may have retired, but they want to meet new people. So there are a lot of different factors at work here, and the pay is not necessarily the most important one. Is it more common for people to sort of wind down and maybe go to 50% on their current job or maybe come back in a consulting position where they used to work? Well, it mostly happened among people who had higher levels of education, especially for people who had professional jobs. So then in that case, actually, this kind of phased retirement or the same organization bridge employment happens more often.
他们享受工作中的社交关系。有时你可能会遇到一位稍微年长一点的优步司机，他可能已经退休了，但他想结识新朋友。所以这里有很多不同的因素在起作用，薪水不一定是最重要的一个。人们是否更倾向于逐渐减少工作量，比如在当前的工作岗位上只做 50%，或者以顾问的身份回到以前工作的地方？嗯，这种情况多发生在受教育程度较高的人群中，尤其是从事专业工作的人。在这种情况下，这种阶段性退休或在同一组织内的桥梁就业确实发生得更频繁。
So basically, people may gradually cutting down their work hours, but still work for the same organization. Or people work for the same organization, but on a less demanding. job roles, like, for example, as you mentioned, advisory roles or consulting roles. But this happens a lot with professional jobs. We don't see it as much for the more labor-intensive jobs. Now, a moment ago, we talked a little bit about the impact of the pandemic on how people are thinking about retirement. And I'm just wondering, are workers who have been able to work remotely more likely to delay retirement? So the research evidence on this is not conclusive yet.
所以基本上，人们可能会逐渐减少工作时间，但仍然为同一个组织工作。或者人们为同一个组织工作，但担任要求较低的职位，例如，正如您提到的，顾问角色。但这在专业工作中发生得很多。我们在劳动密集型工作中并没有看到那么多这种情况。刚才，我们谈到了疫情对人们退休观念的影响。我只是想知道，那些能够远程办公的劳动者是否更有可能推迟退休？关于这一点的研究证据尚无定论。
What we know is when organizations offer flexible working arrangement, they are more likely to keep their older workers. So older workers are less likely to retire if the organization allow them to work from home, such as remote work. Or organizations allow them to select the time when they work. do their work. But in general, we don't know whether remote work is keeping people on their jobs or remote work may make people realize how great it is to not be in the office. So there's still some more research need to be done. Now, you and other researchers have studied how retirement affects people's physical and mental health and their well-being. Is retirement generally good for people's health or bad or what does it depend on? What are the factors that go into making a happy,
我们所知道的是，当组织提供灵活的工作安排时，他们更有可能留住老年员工。因此，如果组织允许他们在家办公（例如远程工作），老年员工退休的可能性就较小。或者组织允许他们选择工作时间。但总的来说，我们不知道远程工作是让人留在了岗位上，还是让人们意识到不用去办公室有多好。所以还需要进行更多的研究。现在，您和其他研究人员已经研究了退休如何影响人们的身体和心理健康以及他们的幸福感。退休对人们的健康通常是有益的还是有害的？或者这取决于什么？哪些因素决定了一个幸福、
healthy retirement versus one that isn't so happy or healthy? Well, this is a great question. So actually, we had nationally representative data to look into this issue. And actually, countering the typical belief that retirement may be good or bad, actually, we found for 70 to 75 percent of the retirees, retirement doesn't do a lot to their own. well-being. So people actually, when they retire, they were able to carry on what they experienced before. They actually were able to maintain their well-being status. So retirement doesn't, to majority of people, retirement doesn't actually create a bad situation for their well-being and the retirement does not create a super good situation for their well-being. However, as you said, right, everything depends. So, we found actually for retirees who retire from stressful jobs and very physically demanding jobs, actually retirement is a very good thing. So that's actually about like 5% of the workers.
健康的退休生活与一个不那么幸福或健康的退休生活？嗯，这是一个很好的问题。实际上，我们有全国代表性的数据来研究这个问题。而且，与退休可能好或坏的典型信念相反，我们发现对于 70% 到 75% 的退休人员来说，退休对他们自身的幸福感并没有太大影响。人们在退休时，能够延续他们之前的经历。他们实际上能够维持自己的幸福感状态。所以对大多数人来说，退休并没有给他们的幸福感带来糟糕的情况，退休也没有给他们的幸福感带来超级好的情况。然而，正如您所说，一切都取决于具体情况。所以，我们发现对于那些从压力大和体力要求高的工作中退休的人来说，退休实际上是一件非常好的事情。这大约占劳动者的 5%。
So when they retire, they actually experience a really good well-being improvement from those stressful jobs. And then we also see about 20 to 25% of workers when they retire. they actually experience some well-being decrease. And that's usually because they may retire from a job that has higher status. They may retire experiencing some financial difficulties. But also, they may have better marital quality. So when they retire, actually, the retirement becomes a very difficult situation for them to manage and adjust. So, yeah, but in general, as I mentioned earlier, like a majority of workers, when they retire, actually, they're able to maintain their well-being situation, and the retirement is not going to have huge impact to their well-being.
所以当他们退休时，他们确实从那些压力大的工作中获得了很好的幸福感提升。然后我们也看到大约 20% 到 25% 的劳动者在退休时，他们的幸福感实际上有所下降。这通常是因为他们可能从一个地位较高的工作中退休。他们可能在退休时经历了一些经济困难。但他们也可能有更好的婚姻质量。所以当他们退休时，退休实际上成为了他们难以管理和适应的局面。所以，是的，但总的来说，正如我之前提到的，大多数劳动者在退休时，实际上能够维持他们的幸福感状态，退休不会对他们的幸福感产生巨大的影响。
What about people who identify so closely with their jobs? What happens to them if you're an attorney and then you walk away and you can't say anymore, I'm a lawyer because you're not really working in the field? what does that do to people's sense of self? That's a very good point. So actually, the work-related identity is very important for a lot of people in professional jobs. So actually, removing them from job or like fully exit their job roles is going to create an negative impact because the work-related identity actually synonymous with their self-identity. So that's why actually bridging employment can help, right?
那些与工作联系非常紧密的人呢？如果他们退休了会怎样？如果你是一名律师，然后你离开了，你不能再说“我是一名律师”，因为你并没有真正从事这个领域的工作，这对人们的自我意识有什么影响？这是一个很好的观点。所以实际上，与工作相关的身份对于许多从事专业工作的人来说非常重要。因此，将他们从工作中移除或完全退出他们的工作角色会产生负面影响，因为与工作相关的身份实际上与他们的自我身份是同义的。这就是为什么桥梁就业可以提供帮助，对吧？
So if you keep doing some work as you done before retirement, it helps you to ease into this new self-identity of retirement and also help you to adjust to this transition better. Well, speaking of adjusting to the transition, let me ask a question for our younger listeners who may feel like retirement is very far away. What should they be thinking about right now? I mean, other than socking away money, how can they plan today for a good retirement that might be 30 years away? So I would say, like, this is related to the career choice, right? So basically, younger workers, right, so they may need to think carefully about what kind of career they will enjoy the most, right? And right, as I mentioned, right? So if their job is very stressful, then actually they may not enjoy the job that much,
所以如果你继续做一些退休前做过的工作，它能帮助你轻松进入这种新的退休自我身份，也能帮助你更好地适应这种过渡。说到适应过渡，让我为我们那些觉得退休还很遥远的年轻听众问一个问题。他们现在应该考虑什么？我的意思是，除了存钱，他们今天如何为可能在 30 年后的美好退休生活做计划？所以我想说，这与职业选择有关，对吧？所以基本上，年轻的劳动者需要仔细考虑他们最喜欢什么样的职业，对吧？正如我提到的，如果他们的工作压力很大，那么他们可能就不会那么享受这份工作，
and they may actually not do much bridge employment or not much paid work activities later on. But then we know that is not good for them to keep their time occupied and also not good for maintaining a productive life structure. So actually, find a job that you really enjoy helps a lot. So, yeah, I would argue that younger workers need to know what they like and also need to find meaningful work so that then when the time comes to retire, they can actually transition through with some bridge employment opportunities and then into retirement feeling accomplished for their career life.
他们以后可能就不会做太多的桥梁就业或有偿工作活动。但我们知道，这对于占据他们的时间以及维持富有成效的生活结构来说并不好。所以实际上，找到一份你真正喜欢的工作会有很大帮助。所以，是的，我认为年轻的劳动者需要知道他们喜欢什么，也需要找到有意义的工作，这样当退休时间到来时，他们实际上可以通过一些桥梁就业机会过渡到退休，并对他们的职业生涯感到满足。
What about for people who are closer to retirement? What are the emotional and practical questions they should be asking themselves when they're trying to decide if the time is right to walk away? Oh, so there are several questions they should ask themselves. So first of all, like what they would like to do in retirement, right? So that's activity-related planning. So basically they need to consider like without working, right, how can they be productive? Right. So not everyone actually enjoy being productive, but actually being productive is a human agency. So it gives us a sense of accomplishment. So it's actually pretty helpful if you plan about that.
对于那些更接近退休的人呢？当他们试图决定是否是时候离开时，他们应该问自己哪些情感和实际问题？哦，他们应该问自己几个问题。首先，他们退休后想做什么，对吧？这是与活动相关的规划。所以基本上他们需要考虑，在不工作的情况下，他们如何才能保持高效？并不是每个人都喜欢保持高效，但实际上保持高效是一种人类能动性。它给了我们一种成就感。所以如果你对此进行规划，实际上非常有帮助。
And then of course you should plan about the leisure activities. Right. So basically know what you like and then how you would enjoy those activities when you retire. Right. So but regardless of what you choose, these activities can help meet needs that were once filled by their work. Right. So like having social interactions and the structured time. So that's the first thing, the activity. The second thing is actually people should think about where they want to live. Right. So because when we enter the later stage of our life, a lot of time we have unique health care needs. We actually probably where we typically live may not be very accessible for those kind of assistance.
然后当然你应该规划休闲活动。基本上知道你喜欢什么，以及当你退休时如何享受这些活动。无论你选择什么，这些活动都可以帮助满足曾经由工作满足的需求。比如拥有社交互动和结构化的时间。所以这是第一件事，活动。第二件事是人们应该考虑他们想住在哪里。因为当我们进入生命的后期阶段时，很多时候我们有独特的医疗保健需求。我们通常居住的地方可能不太方便获得那种援助。
So actually think about where to live and can access useful services is very important. And then the third question is how, basically how you want to, who you want to share retirement with. Okay. So basically in retirement, more than just lifestyle changes. Actually, relationships and one sense of self can change as well. So oftentimes we rely on our spouses as a main area of focus like for spending retirement with. But then also there are other relationships, right? So like children, grandchildren, parents, friends, or even like lovely neighbors.
所以考虑住在哪里以及能否获得有用的服务非常重要。第三个问题是，基本上你想和谁分享退休生活。在退休生活中，不仅仅是生活方式的改变。实际上，人际关系和自我意识也会发生变化。所以我们经常依赖配偶作为我们退休生活的主要关注点。但还有其他人际关系，比如孩子、孙辈、父母、朋友，甚至是可爱的邻居。
Right. So, yeah, think about who you want to retire with, like spend that time with for retirement planning is very important. Now, you also study older workers and you've looked at what companies can do to attract and retain them. Why is it important for companies and organizations to think about this? What's the benefit of older workers? Oh, the issue is especially in the United States, actually, we know the workforce is aging, right? So, and we're not really enlarging our workforce that much. So keeping older workers on jobs actually help us to fulfill those job positions.
所以，思考你想和谁一起退休，一起度过那段退休时光，对于退休规划非常重要。现在，您也研究老年劳动者，并且您已经研究了公司可以做些什么来吸引和留住他们。为什么公司和组织考虑这一点很重要？老年劳动者的好处是什么？哦，这个问题特别是在美国，我们知道劳动力正在老龄化，对吧？而且我们并没有真正扩大我们的劳动力。所以让老年劳动者留在岗位上实际上有助于我们填补这些职位。
So think about right now, like we have a big inflation situation. And largely this is because of a labor force shortage, right? So there are way more jobs than actually there are supply of labor force. So actually keeping other workers in organizations help meet the labor force demand. But also, other workers often have more experience, work experiences, and they have a lot more knowledge about the organization. So actually, keeping older workers can keep the organizations productivity high and also help passing the useful knowledge to the next generation.
所以想想现在，我们有严重的通货膨胀情况。这在很大程度上是因为劳动力短缺，对吧？所以工作岗位远多于劳动力供给。因此，让老年劳动者留在组织中确实有助于满足劳动力需求。而且，老年劳动者通常有更多的经验，工作经验，并且他们对组织有更多的了解。所以实际上，留住老年劳动者可以保持组织的高生产力，也有助于将有用的知识传给下一代。
So that's why it's very important to keep older workers on their jobs. What about the notion that older workers not being digital natives are not able to keep up with changes in technology? I mean, mightn't that make them more of a burden than an asset in some workplaces? Well, actually, this is a myth. So basically, we say like older workers, not digital natives. But that's because when they were growing up,
这就是为什么让老年劳动者留在岗位上非常重要。关于老年劳动者不是数字原住民，无法跟上技术变革的说法呢？我的意思是，这会不会使他们在某些工作场所成为负担而不是资产？嗯，实际上，这是一个误区。所以基本上，我们说老年劳动者不是数字原住民。但那是因为当他们成长时，
there were no such digital devices. So basically, like a lot of older workers, when they grew up, there were no iPhones, right? There may not even be computers or like PCs. So actually, the key here is not like whether they grew up with the device or not. The key here is whether we offer sufficient training opportunities on using those devices.
没有这样的数字设备。所以基本上，很多老年劳动者在成长时，没有 iPhone，对吧？甚至可能没有电脑或个人电脑。所以这里的关键不是他们是否伴随着设备成长。这里的关键是我们是否提供了关于使用这些设备的充分培训机会。
Actually, the research actually points to like for older workers, if you give them sufficient time, they actually can go through those training pretty effectively. Actually, they're learning for the digital technology is as efficient as younger workers. So, yeah, so here is a training opportunity issue rather than, you know, whether they grew up with it or not. Well, on behalf of older workers, I thank you. You were quoted in an article last year about Target doing away with its mandatory retirement age for executives. And that used to be pretty common that big corporations had mandatory retirement ages. Does this reflect a broader trend away from mandatory retirement ages in general?
实际上，研究表明对于老年劳动者，如果你给他们足够的时间，他们实际上可以非常有效地完成这些培训。实际上，他们对数字技术的学习和年轻劳动者一样高效。所以，这是一个培训机会的问题，而不是他们是否伴随着它成长的问题。好吧，我代表老年劳动者感谢您。您去年在一篇文章中被引用，谈到塔吉特百货取消了高管的强制退休年龄。过去，大公司有强制退休年龄是很常见的。这是否反映了普遍远离强制退休年龄的更广泛趋势？
And do you think that's a good thing? Well, first of all, in the United States, because of the ADA law, actually mandatory retirement is generally. generally illegal, right? So only for certain occupations, actually mandatory retirement is legal. And then the CEO job or high-level paid executive job is an exception to the ADA law, which allows the company board to include a mandatory retirement clause in the contract. So then when the CEO turned to 65 or 67, they cannot stay on the job anymore. But we see a trend that this is a lot more companies actually abolishing that kind of clause.
您认为这是一件好事吗？嗯，首先，在美国，由于《美国残疾人法案》（ADA），强制退休通常是非法的，对吧？只有某些职业，强制退休才是合法的。而首席执行官职位或高薪高管职位是 ADA 法案的一个例外，它允许公司董事会在合同中加入强制退休条款。所以当首席执行官年满 65 或 67 岁时，他们就不能再留在岗位上了。但我们看到一个趋势，越来越多的公司正在废除这种条款。
Why? Because actually nowadays older executives, like they probably have way better physical caring, physical condition than probably 50 years ago. And so they are more capable of doing their work. And then also there's a lot more technology assistance that can help people accomplish their work. So actually, I don't see whether there's like arbitrary age that people should retire. So, yeah, so basically I think the trend will keep going as in the U.S. at least, like we already know, we already recognize mandatory retirement is not necessary. And then in Europe, we see actually the mandatory retirement age kept being delayed.
为什么？因为如今的老年高管，他们的身体状况可能比 50 年前好得多。所以他们更有能力完成工作。而且还有更多的技术辅助可以帮助人们完成工作。所以，我不认为有什么任意的年龄是人们应该退休的。所以，基本上我认为这个趋势会持续下去，至少在美国，我们已经认识到强制退休是不必要的。而在欧洲，我们看到强制退休年龄一直在推迟。
And on the one hand, it reflects that workers are more capable and they can have longer work life. And then on the other hand, of course, there's a social institutional concern, which is if you want to keep a good retirement benefit, people may have to work a little bit longer to recruit those benefits. Now, you mentioned Europe, and there's, of course, a big dispute going on in France right now around raising the retirement age from 62 to 64, which those of us in the U.S., find almost funny, but I mean, there's a reason for it. The reason is that there's a huge infrastructure that pays people pensions and health care when they reach that age. If it were more, maybe this is not a fair question, but I mean, we don't have anything quite similar in the United States. I mean, if we had something like that, would you foresee that people would be likely to retire sooner? For example, suddenly Social Security,
一方面，它反映了劳动者更有能力，他们可以有更长的职业生涯。另一方面，当然，存在社会制度方面的担忧，即如果你想保持良好的退休福利，人们可能必须工作更长时间才能获得这些福利。现在，您提到了欧洲，当然，法国目前围绕将退休年龄从 62 岁提高到 64 岁存在巨大的争议，我们这些在美国的人觉得这几乎很有趣，但我的意思是，这是有原因的。原因是有一个巨大的基础设施，在人们达到那个年龄时支付养老金和医疗保健。如果更多的话，也许这不是一个公平的问题，但我的意思是，我们在美国没有类似的东西。我的意思是，如果我们有类似的东西，您是否预见到人们会更早退休？例如，突然社会保障，
became so flush with cash that they doubled the payout that they were giving everybody. Then when we all leave our jobs. Wow, that's a really interesting point. So I think human nature would dictate that if we have abundant resources, of course, we want to have more autonomy and we may not want to stay on the job much longer, right, especially if the financial resources is available. So but I think the thing is that everything you receive will have to be paid by someone, right? So the retirement system is a pay-as-you-go system, which means the benefit we receive is actually paid by the younger generation. Right. So we need to be very mindful about this, which is actually right now the supportive ratio is about a little bit more than two workers supporting one retiree.
变得资金充足，以至于他们将给每个人的支出翻了一番。那么我们都会离开我们的工作吗？哇，这是一个非常有趣的问题。所以我认为人性决定了如果我们有丰富的资源，当然，我们想要更多的自主权，我们可能不想在岗位上待太久，对吧，特别是如果经济资源可用的话。但我认为问题在于你收到的每一分钱都必须由某人支付，对吧？所以退休制度是一个现收现付制，这意味着我们收到的福利实际上是由年轻一代支付的。所以我们需要非常注意这一点，即目前抚养比大约是两个多一点的劳动者抚养一个退休人员。
Okay, unless there's a big population growth, like I don't think the retirement benefit will be continuing going better. And the U.S., actually, the support ratio is actually pretty stable in the past 20 years. So there are some countries actually the support ratio keeps going down. It's dangerously low, like, for example, like 1.3 workers supporting one retiree. then everyone actually ended up not having enough benefits. So, yeah, so I would say, like, although we all want to receive more benefits, we need to be mindful, like, not to add too much pressure to the next generation. So in that case, also like the U.S., the big job labor force, like a new addition to the labor force,
好的，除非有巨大的人口增长，否则我不认为退休福利会持续变好。在美国，抚养比在过去 20 年里实际上相当稳定。所以有些国家抚养比一直在下降。它低得危险，例如，1.3 个劳动者抚养一个退休人员。那么每个人最终都没有足够的福利。所以，我会说，虽然我们都想获得更多的福利，但我们需要注意，不要给下一代增加太大的压力。所以在这种情况下，也像美国一样，庞大的劳动力，即劳动力的补充，
is always immigrants. So, yeah, so the Congress and the government should pay attention to the, immigration reform reform and see how we can keep supply good labor force. Now, you worked on a report from the National Academy of Sciences that looked at generational differences in the workforce, and it seems that the upshot was that it's not really helpful to use generational differences as a frame for understanding workers' needs, things like categorizing workers as baby boomers or Gen X or millennials. Why is that not a useful way to think about workers' needs?
总是移民。所以，国会和政府应该关注移民改革，看看我们如何保持良好的劳动力供给。现在，您参与了美国国家科学院的一份报告，该报告研究了劳动力中的代际差异，似乎结论是使用代际差异作为理解劳动者需求的框架并没有什么帮助，比如将劳动者归类为婴儿潮一代、X 世代或千禧一代。为什么这不是思考劳动者需求的一种有用方式？
Well, so we actually, as a committee, we reviewed the literature in this area. And what we found is actually oftentimes when you categorize workers based on their generations, it just represents a covert way of age discrimination. It could be either discriminating older workers or discriminating younger workers, right? Because when we categorize people into different generations, it allows us to say something like, oh, that's just a baby boomer. Or that's just like an X generation. Right. So what we found was this kind of categorization actually promotes stereotypes.
嗯，我们作为一个委员会，回顾了该领域的文献。我们发现，实际上，当你根据代际对劳动者进行分类时，它往往代表了一种隐蔽的年龄歧视。它可能是歧视老年劳动者，也可能是歧视年轻劳动者，对吧？因为当我们把人分成不同的世代时，它允许我们说一些话，比如，“哦，那只是一个婴儿潮一代。”或者“那只是 X 世代。”所以我们发现这种分类实际上助长了刻板印象。
And also it mainly resulted from imprecise use of the terminology in the popular literature. Okay, so but then it does not really inform effective workforce management decisions. So that's why in the report we actually cautioned the public that to use those language may be more harmful than efficient. And of course, after we review the literature, we also found that scientifically actually a lot of those research cannot really capture the generational differences. that they intend to capture. Methodologically, they are very flawed.
而且它主要是由于大众文献中对术语的不精确使用造成的。好的，但这并不能真正为有效的劳动力管理决策提供信息。这就是为什么在报告中我们实际上告诫公众，使用这些语言可能弊大于利。当然，在我们回顾文献后，我们也发现从科学上讲，实际上很多这些研究并不能真正捕捉到他们想要捕捉的代际差异。在方法论上，它们是非常有缺陷的。
So that's also scientifically a reason we shouldn't take those kind of differences too seriously. Let me ask you a question on a different topic. You also study how employers are using artificial intelligence in the workplace and hiring decisions. And there's a lot of talk about bias in AI, but are you actually hoping to find ways to use AI to improve fairness and hiring? I mean, can you talk about that a little bit? Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, definitely. So fairness in AI is mainly created as a research topic
所以这也是我们不应该太认真对待这些差异的科学原因。让我问您一个不同话题的问题。您还研究雇主如何在工作场所和招聘决策中使用人工智能。关于人工智能中的偏见有很多讨论，但您是否真的希望找到使用人工智能来提高招聘公平性的方法？我的意思是，您能谈谈这一点吗？哦，是的，当然。所以人工智能中的公平性主要是作为一个研究课题被创建的，
because we found that to use artificial intelligence, we're basically asking an algorithm to learn about existing data. However, existing data contains bias, right? So when the artificial intelligence is learning about existing data, you actually learned about the human bias in those, contained in those data. So the result is that when you use artificial intelligence, maybe it's very fast to make a recommendation, or maybe it's very fast to help you make decisions. But it also contains the human bias that actually you have no way to identify.
因为我们发现使用人工智能，我们基本上是在要求算法学习现有数据。然而，现有数据包含偏见，对吧？所以当人工智能在学习现有数据时，你实际上学习了这些数据中包含的人类偏见。结果是，当你使用人工智能时，也许它做出建议非常快，或者也许它能非常快地帮助你做出决策。但它也包含了你无法识别的人类偏见。
So for example, like if you're a HR manager, you're trying to decide. whether you want to hire an older worker. So you would caution yourself as, hey, I cannot have age discrimination when I make this decision. However, if you're using AI to make that decision, AI would just rely on whatever data it's learning. And you will know how AI made that decision. So even correcting for it is a little bit harder. So that created this whole need for research on fairness AI. So my recent research has been looking at given the current policy in terms of EEOC has this adverse impact ratio on criteria.
所以例如，如果你是一名人力资源经理，你正试图决定是否要雇佣一名老年劳动者。你会告诫自己，嘿，我在做这个决定时不能有年龄歧视。然而，如果你使用人工智能来做那个决定，人工智能只会依赖它正在学习的任何数据。你将知道人工智能是如何做出那个决定的。所以即使纠正它也比较困难。所以这创造了对公平人工智能研究的整个需求。所以我最近的研究一直在关注，鉴于 EEOC 在标准方面有这种不利影响比率的当前政策，
So how do we make sure that our hiring decision is not favoring one category of the population versus another category of the population? So it's a lot about finding out what AI is capable. finding out also how to avoid bias that is embedded in the algorithm. Last question, just to wrap up, what are the big issues that you're working on now? I mean, what would you like to have the answers to that you're studying today? Oh, so I'm recently studying a lot on the age and the technology use. So earlier we talked about this, right, so in terms of digital natives or like digital exclusion. I'm looking at how we actually eliminate the issue of digital exclusion.
我们如何确保我们的招聘决策不会偏袒人口中的某一个类别而不是另一个类别？所以这很大程度上是关于找出人工智能的能力，也找出如何避免嵌入在算法中的偏见。最后一个问题，总结一下，您现在正在研究哪些重大问题？我的意思是，您今天正在研究的问题，您希望得到什么答案？哦，我最近在研究很多关于年龄和技术使用的问题。所以早些时候我们谈到了这一点，关于数字原住民或数字排斥。我正在研究我们如何真正消除数字排斥的问题。
And so the research actually right now, what we found is actually digital exclusion often comes in four different ways. One is the hardware exclusion, which is for other people, it's a little bit harder for them to access the most up-to-date the digital technology in terms of devices. Then the second form is actually the software exclusion. So oftentimes it is harder for older workers or other people to track what's the most efficient software to use. And for example, on the phone, like what's the most efficient app to use? So that's the software exclusion. And then the third one is actually more macro, which is exclusion in the form of information. So for example, in terms of information and the infrastructure, right?
所以研究实际上现在，我们发现数字排斥通常以四种不同的方式出现。一种是硬件排斥，即对于老年人来说，他们获取最新数字技术设备稍微困难一些。第二种形式是软件排斥。所以通常老年劳动者或老年人很难追踪使用什么最高效的软件。例如，在手机上，使用什么最高效的应用程序？所以那是软件排斥。第三个实际上更宏观，即信息形式的排斥。例如，在信息和基础设施方面，
So if the government do not actually install those fiber optics equipment for the rural area, then it's very difficult for people living in that area to access information. And also we know, like in some countries, like they have great firewalls that keep all the information out. So that's also a way of exclusion. And then the last type is actually exclusion. due to privacy concerns, right? So this is especially important for older people because oftentimes when we are surfing our internet,
如果政府实际上没有为农村地区安装那些光纤设备，那么居住在该地区的人们就很难获取信息。而且我们也知道，在一些国家，他们有很棒的防火墙，把所有信息都挡在外面。所以这也是一种排斥方式。最后一种实际上是由于隐私担忧导致的排斥，对吧？所以这对老年人来说尤其重要，因为通常当我们上网时，
when we use apps, we're not aware that our privacy is being infringed down. Oftentimes we're asked to provide information about ourselves, about our family, and those information can be used in the cyberspace. cyberspace. So yeah, so that's another form of exclusion like basically you creates risk for older people. So yeah, so my recent research is really focusing on how to reduce digital exclusion for older workers and also for older people and to
当我们使用应用程序时，我们没有意识到我们的隐私正在受到侵犯。通常我们被要求提供关于我们自己、关于我们家庭的信息，而这些信息可以在网络空间中使用。所以是的，这是另一种形式的排斥，基本上它为老年人创造了风险。所以，我最近的研究确实专注于如何减少老年劳动者和老年人的数字排斥，并
use, make sure those digital technologies are used for their well-being to create a better life rather than actually creating risks for them. Well, Dr. Wang, this has been really great. I appreciate you're taking the time to talk to us today. Okay. Thank you very much. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.
确保这些数字技术被用于他们的幸福，创造更好的生活，而不是实际上为他们创造风险。王博士，这真的太棒了。我很感谢您抽出时间今天与我们交谈。好的。非常感谢。感谢您的邀请。您可以在我们的网站 www. 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的节目。
www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. And again, we'd like to hear from you about what you think of this podcast and what you'd like to hear more of from us. so please go to our website, www.combeatingof psychology.org, and look for a link to the listener's survey.
www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方。如果您喜欢您所听到的，请给我们留下评论。再次，我们想听听您对这个播客的看法，以及您想从我们这里听到更多什么。所以请访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org，并查找听众调查问卷的链接。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您有对未来播客的评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪安。感谢您的收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。